[Musique]
Jean-Michel Bourgault bonjour bonjour
vous avez prononcé il y a quelques jours
vos vœux dans une grande série au
Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
on reviendra d'ailleurs sur le robot
il y a beaucoup de mots qui ont été pour
danser d'innovation de développement
économique de développement aussi
numérique production scientifique
technologique on va revenir sur tous ces
mots mais le passage d'une année sur
l'autre ça permet de faire un peu le
point sur les gros événements qui sont
passés sur ce qui a été fait et
justement va s'arrêter une seconde
là-dessus il y a eu la crise sanitaire
qui semble un peu maintenant derrière
nous même si rien n'est rien n'est
jamais joué et puis la guerre aux
Ukraine avec la montée de l'inflation la
montée aussi des dépenses énergétiques
vous quelles sont les ou font les
événements que vous retenez qui vous
semble très très important encore
aujourd'hui
écoutez la crise sanitaire tous les 12
mai ont été touchés par ça au bout du
sentier mort on
cette décision difficile mais
opérationnelle de prendre qu'un seul
centre et non pas 12 centres quand on a
vu l'urgence de vacciner les gens
donc ce vaccinodrome qui a été décidé
sur le vélodrome a été très opérationnel
on a vacciné 400 000 personnes dans les
meilleures conditions
je veux dire qu'on a créé d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui c'est le Centre national
anti pandémique d'urgence donc tout est
prêt si demande avait une autre pandémie
en trois jours on peut réarmer avec des
moyens voilà donc ça c'est rassurant en
termes de protection de nos de nos de
nos cinq continents administrés voilà ça
on a eu je vous rappelle comme c'est
grave il y a eu 15 millions de morts
c'est quand même l'équivant de la
Première Guerre mondiale cette pandémie
donc on a bien protégé en tout cas
Saint-Quentin et d'ailleurs d'une façon
on a joué un rôle important dedans on
est très contents donc c'est une des
choses qui vous a assez la chose qui
nous a le plus le Market 200 morts quand
même sur Saint-Quentin bah justement
parce que vous parlez beaucoup des des
valeurs de l'entreprise vous souhaitez
aussi une gestion très rigoureuse de
l'argent public mais il y a peut-être un
mot et vous venez de le prononcer qui
peut être résumer tout ça et qu'on a
peut-être plus inattendu c'est le mode
protection
ce qui guide au fond vos actions oui
parce que on le voit en matière de
protection les attentes des administrées
c'est aujourd'hui c'est le pouvoir
d'achat c'est à Sony l'emploi bon donc
pour les protéger il faut protéger leur
emploi par exemple ici
Saint-Quentin il y a eu deux
parlementaires qui ont fait voter le
crédit pour recherche enfin c'est
essentiellement quand même
vérifier voilà et et vraiment ça a
protégé les cerveaux ça protéger
l'intelligence qui est restée en France
dans beaucoup de grands groupes et ça ça
protégeait vraiment les entreprises
leurs capacités de rester innovantes
de protection c'est vrai en matière de
santé vous venez de le dire avec le
vaccin de Drôme mais c'est vrai aussi
sur les entreprises c'est vrai aussi sur
l'éducation on en parlera avec le
numérique c'est aussi une façon de
protéger les enfants par rapport aux
difficultés du monde actuel enfin aux
enjeux du monde actuel en tout cas donc
c'est un mot qui qui me semble revenir
au fond dans toutes vos actions
mais par exemple on a protégé aussi nos
entreprises en termes de capitaux parce
que le problème en France
cette culture antiquapitalistique
militante donc on voit pas très bien
l'objectif
c'est que on a fait passer un amendement
et c'est également issu des
parlementaires de Saint-Quentin qui a
pris 100 milliards sur l'épargne des
Français qui est souvent stérilisé dans
dans la caution de la dette de l'État et
on a pris 100 milliards pour plutôt les
fertiliser en les envoyant sur à
renforcer les fonds de l'entreprise
évident que sous certaines conditions de
sécurisantes pour les épargnants mais ça
c'est pareil c'est un grand moment de
protéger nos entreprises parce que c'est
quand même eux qui font la richesse je
vous rappelle qu'une entreprise ça
redistribue plus de 50% de son chiffre
d'affaires en social et en fiscal donc
comme j'ai dit l'Abbé Pierre quand j'ai
dit l'histoire que c'était les
entreprises c'est l'abbé Pierre parce
que voilà c'est c'est bien de
redistribuer la richesse c'était le
moment facile vous savez mais c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de la produire
aujourd'hui
il faut former plus de talent qui vont
sur l'entreprise et dire ici en
formation on met le paquet sur le
numérique sur tous les secteurs
stratégiques de haute valeur ajoutée
avec des compétences bien sûr très
pointues parce que c'est c'est ça
l'enjeu c'est de protéger aussi de
donner accès aux entreprises aux
meilleurs talents le premier talent
c'est de trouver les talents donc on
rentre dans également dans cette action
avec l'automobile donc vous voyez
protection de l'entreprise des cerveaux
de la recherche bon parmi c'est clair
alors on va venir justement
arrêtons-nous un instant sur est-ce
qu'on va passer en revue un peu les
grands thèmes qui sont ceux de l'année
2023 justement les entreprises et c'est
vrai que c'est un territoire ici avec
Rédé avec Thalès Airbus afro enfin pour
multiplier le nombre d'entreprises je
crois qu'il y en a 600 à peu près sur ce
territoire qu'est-ce qui fait au sens il
y en a 600 qui sont bien sûr très
secteur stratégique
qu'est-ce qu'elle qu'est-ce qu'elle
trouve sur ce territoire pourquoi elle
s'en plante ici
à 30 minutes de Paris or encombrement
par l'autoroute vous pouvez arriver du
périphérique à Saint-Quentin 100 feux
rouges bon donc bien sûr c'est un
avantage bon deuxièmement c'est la ville
à la campagne où c'est une partie quand
même vous avez 60% du territoire qui
n'est pas urbanisé contrairement et donc
c'est un jour vous seriez pris comme ça
ce qu'il faut pas faire ce qui fait
toujours mais vous vous rendez compte
voilà c'est quand même un territoire
assez sympathique là-dessus
troisièmement il y a des centres de
formation très pointus il y a des écoles
quand vous faites devenir des talents ou
de rajouter bien sûr la première chose
que les ingénieurs c'est je vais mettre
mes enfants dans quelle école
forcément c'est un quant à Paris c'est
clair vous avez quand même des alcools
très prestigieuses dont Paris première
université scientifique au monde en
mathématiques Polytechnique qui disait
d'abord
vous avez donc forcément c'est un
élément d'attractivité pour les
ingénieurs qui veulent qu'on a un niveau
d'exigence très élevée pour les enfants
après vous avez
je dirais tout un environnement bien sûr
sportif très important vous avez des
équipements sportifs de très haut niveau
la preuve c'est pas un hasard si
Saint-Quentin et l'agglomération qui a
eu le plus de sites olympiques et on en
a quatre
tout ça ça fait c'est ça qui fait un
territoire dans lequel les entreprises
se sentent bien quoi il y a la formation
il y a l'intelligence il y a le et il y
a la qualité de vie en gros c'est ça
absolument il y a même la mobilité
puisque on construit les pistes sociales
on a quand même plus de 400 km déjà
depuis ce cyclables mais nos nos
administrer on veut le plus on va passer
à plus de 600 km surtout que comme on a
trois sites olympiques sur les quatre
des choix de toute façon alors fallait
pas y aller donc on le fait donc ça bien
sûr c'est appréciable et trottinettes
aussi des trucs électriques pour les
jeunes je crois que plus d'un million de
trajet depuis qu'on a lancé ça donc ont
été parce qu'il y a des morts quand même
confondez pas Paris
effectivement alors d'abord faut faut je
peux pas changer mon anniv à gauche
c'est que c'est la mode mais bon mais
c'est vrai que vous avez un niveau
d'urbanisation qui est très élevé il y a
une des voitures qui se touchent
quasiment c'est pas le même il faisait
d'abord vous avez beaucoup plus de
pistes cyclables au kilomètre bien sûr
donc ces différents ça fonctionne bien
entre les vélos les trottinettes sur les
sur les pistes cyclables avec les
projets de développement c'est quand
même assez sympa bon vous avez des
choses assez sympa même l'île de loisirs
ça va être un peu transformé en sorte de
voir tout ça
je reviens aux entreprises alors il y a
un gros problème qu'on rencontre les
entreprises aujourd'hui c'est qu'elles
offrent des emplois elle trouve pas de
gens pour employer enfin il y a une
vraie crise il y a aussi un gros effort
de formation alors je pense qu'à ce qui
emploie je pense à ce qui va se passer
au mois d'avril skit
au Vélodrome là aussi c'est un des c'est
au fond une démission de de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin de
d'essayer de fournir les emplois que
demande les entreprises ah oui nous on a
une grosse préoccupation alors d'abord
on a un appareil éducatif vous savez qui
est plutôt un modèle français qui a déjà
d'ailleurs été
on a été invité à l'Exposition
universelle de Dubaï pour présenter
l'innovation française en étant le
numérique sur le numérique bon et il y a
une espèce de continuum ici qui qui qui
se développe entre
le primaire l'école primaire le
secondaire jusqu'à l'université pour
qu'on est une formation beaucoup plus
avec des outils beaucoup plus
scientifiques beaucoup plus attractif
donc
et qui vous emmène effectivement qui
développe plus une culture scientifique
il faut le dire mais aujourd'hui c'est
un enjeu considérable demain si vous
voulez résoudre les problèmes du monde
c'est bien de faire un doctoresse c'est
bien de faire un doctorat sur Victor
Hugo Victor Hugo mais ça peut mais dire
que les solutions sont même le
réchauffement la planète vous avez pas
simplement le résoudre par des discours
des commentaires voilà
[Musique]
et on a sacré les meilleurs
mathématiciens du monde et en plus on a
cité effectivement d'être très fier
d'avoir appris à chaque fois bon encore
en 2022 on a un prix Nobel la médaille
effectivement on est très heureux très
fier bien entendu ça ça flatte
d'ailleurs le sentiment d'appartenance
et la reconnaissance bien entendu très
bon laboratoire de R&D bien sûr
très belles entreprises très forte
culture numérique je vous dis des
secteurs stratégiques d'avenir donc bien
sûr que tout ça fait un ensemble mais
sur très attractif quelqu'un qui veut
bien se former qui veut avoir un job
bien sûr bien payé sur un secteur
d'avenir bon alors ensuite il y a la
santé vous avez un mot quand même
justement sur la fusion Paris sacrée du
VSQ est-ce que vous souhaitez je crois
que c'est acté pour un certain nombre de
diversités que le siège des universités
qui sont
dans Versailles Saint-Quentin reste en
place
ah mais de toute façon
l'avion change rien à ça
change rien chacun reste bien sûr
géographiquement sur un site puisque ce
serait coûteux de changer ici comme ça
mais en fait c'est l'unité de de de
direction
en la coordination entre tous ces
diplômes bien sûr qui sont quand même
très nombreux sur l'ensemble des
universités qui sont dans ce dispositif
qui montent d'un degré du fait d'une
meilleure coordination des profs des
enseignements le le redéploiement vers
des aussi vers des des on voit bien les
aspirations du monde les demandes
aujourd'hui ici on est au courant de ce
qui se passe dans le monde on est vous
le savez on est dans dans les 8
territoires les plus innovants au monde
donc on a on a des informations on sait
peut-être mieux inciter nos jeunes aller
vers des domaines de la réussite et le
secteur commercial est très propice donc
en termes de formation en plus on a une
très grande proximité avec l'entreprise
si avec la recherche voyez on a
d'ailleurs la ministre d'éducation
nationale enfin la mise de
l'enseignement sur excusez-moi et de la
Recherche et l'ancienne président donc
tout ça fait un très beau le nouveau
bien sûr pour attirer des gens qui
veulent seulement se former au savoir de
demain il y a évidemment une nouvelle en
course qui apparaissent je pense à la
cyberlinquance là aussi il y a des
écoles comme 2600 sur ce territoire qui
forme à la cybersécurité ça c'est très
important c'est aussi une protection ça
fait partie de protection nécessaire et
on l'a vu des hôpitaux des services
publics et des entreprises alors
évidemment vous avez vous avez bien sûr
matière de cybersécurité qui est le le
grand secteur qui est en train
d'exploser je vous rappelle qu'il y a eu
aux JO de Londres 200 millions
d'attaques j'ai eu de Londres et 4
milliards à Tokyo donc on imagine
que c'était à Paris donc bien entendu
c'est des des là actuellement on est en
investissement très fort sur la
cybersécurité c'est un secteur qui est
vraiment il y a une demande d'emploi et
des secteurs bien sûr hyper stratégiques
parce que de toute façon si vous ne
maîtrisez pas la cybersécurité même
votre tablette vous pouvez le commencer
à le jeter la poubelle parce que ça va
ça va voilà c'est pas une rigolade donc
là on a effectivement
vous l'avez vu
des très belles ambitions
actuellement vous avez Airbus sécurité
défense vous avez Thalès quel numéro un
européen de la cybersécurité qui est là
et bon et Atos on a beaucoup de très
belles entreprises grandes et moyennes
qui travaillent là-dessus donc je crois
que ça c'est et ça mobilise les jeunes
alors vous avez cité l'école de 1600 qui
est un très bel exemple mais on tous les
jours on le le ce campus entre
guillemets de cybersécurité grossi à la
demande des entreprises donc nous on est
on est très en réponse comme vous l'avez
dit quand vous cherchez des talents et
que vous avez du mal à en trouver dans
des très belles entreprises mais il
paraît que c'est pas un phénomène
uniquement français
que dans d'autres pays aussi il y a ça
alors faut dire que on aurait je sais il
y a le club des 50 milliards je sais pas
si vous connaissez l'expression il y a
50 milliards que vous coûte que vous
coûte le chômage c'est plus de 50
milliards on dit que c'est entre 50 et
75 milliards vous imaginez passivement
vous dépensez de l'argent il y a un
moment donné de certaines personnes oui
mais jusqu'à mon temps de 50 milliards
deuxièmement vous avez la fraude sociale
aussi qui coûte un peu plus de 50
milliards et vous avez nos amis
écologistes qui vraiment ont fait preuve
d'une grande intelligence en bien sûr en
détruisant la filière nucléaire et ça va
vous coûter aussi 50 milliards et le
fait de de détruire ça alors que vous
avez pas l'alternative bien entendu vous
allez dépendre bien sûr de les
importations d'énergie et le cou est en
or donc ça a l'air de rien mais tout ça
fait qu'aujourd'hui donc demain faut
vraiment faut vraiment encore en
rajouter dans l'intelligence dans dans
comprendre comment le monde tourne
d'avoir une culture économique d'avoir
une culture scientifique parce que
certes que et managérial d'ailleurs au
passage il y aura un peu plus dans la
classe politique des gens qui viennent
du management de l'entreprise où là vous
avez des obligations de résultats mais
pas seulement des brillants
intelligemment de bien expliquer de bien
commenter de de bien désigner les
coupables c'est bien tout ça mais voilà
dans l'entreprise c'est solution et je
crois qu'ici Saint-Quentin porte cette
nouvelle culture pour nouvelle elle est
dans le pays aussi c'est très porté sur
trouver des solutions aux problèmes un
mot sur la sécurité justement puisqu'il
y a il y a ce commissariat du futur ce
qu'on appelle du futur dans votre ville
elle est au cours de les premiers coups
de purge vont être donnés c'est quoi ce
que c'est quoi un commissariat du futur
c'est un commissariat d'abord qui tient
compte des évolutions bien sûr de de
d'attente des Français
qui qui en même temps et international
parce que l'insécurité aujourd'hui alors
je sais pas vous parler de la sécurité
mondiale aujourd'hui vous avez une
situation quasiment de guerre un truc
quand même des entre eux bien sûr la
Russie l'Ukraine mais peut-être demain
entre la liste des unis et la Chine je
veux dire tout ça et quand même très
insécurisant aujourd'hui bien sûr il
faut alors ça c'est la partie défense
mais la partie c'est sécurité intérieure
oui
l'islamisation bien sûr de beaucoup de
convoi dans beaucoup de pays ils sont
équipés de de voilà de numérique de fin
de ce que souvent de vues dans les
commissariats il y a autrefois encore il
y a pas encore longtemps des des
machines à écrire classique là ça sera
ça sera un commissaire enfin une
sécurité qui utilise les moyens le plus
modernes en tout cas il faut aussi faire
évoluer les méthodes de sécurité il faut
que nos policiers avec grâce à la
révolution numérique qu'il se connecte
mieux qu'on sache où sont les voitures
où sont les hommes voilà de savoir
beaucoup plus ce qui se passe sur le
terrain pour intervenir plus vite pour
pour protéger nos policiers protéger les
victimes aussi bon et puis peut-être
être plus efficace contre contre les
agresseurs quand même et et mieux et
mieux considérer tout le monde parce que
qu'on soit agressé l'agresseur ou le
policier il faut que il faut que tout le
monde quand même puisse se retrouver
dans des situations bon voilà et et tout
cela on se penche sur la modernisation
le côté même rendre plus humain oui
d'avoir moins de victimes qu'elle soit
mieux écouter mieux considérés et puis
que la justice est une meilleure
coordination avec la justice quand on
voit bien sûr des procès qui se passent
deux ans après qui sont une agression là
il faut donc on se penche comment
améliorer la communication les relations
entre entre tous ces acteurs de la
sécurité oui alors les JO évidemment
c'est 2024 on a encore on a encore non
mais la préparation se fait alors il y a
la défait les épreuves de golf ou Golf
National et puis le vélo notamment au
Vélodrome et et à Élancourt sur la
colline Delancourt est-ce que vous êtes
frappé au fond par la mobilisation de la
population sur ce qu'il y a déjà 800
volontaires déjà qui sont fait connaître
des jeunes aussi très son jeunes qui
veulent participer à ça
oui il y a quelques une fierté là aussi
d'accueillir les JO oui mais regardez
jeudi soir assez donc assez vœux où il y
avait quand même 1500 personnes qui sont
passées il y a une fierté l'appartenance
on le sent de quoi collaborateurs devant
de nos partenaires
et puis et puis bien sûr on sent bien
que les JO nous montent aussi d'un étage
parce que c'est c'est oui on a eu plus
d'un milliard de vues sur sur la Ryder
Cup on a eu le pire que actuellement
c'est le vaccinodrome
mais là les JO je crois que le ministre
de rappeler ça c'est 4 milliards de de
vue de gens qui vont nous voir donc bon
là c'est c'est quand même le top c'est
une fois dans votre vie oui vous voyez
ça
en plus ils en ont collé 4
et donc oui c'est une c'est les gens
sont bien sûr les gens sont enchantés
ils sont très fiers on va parler d'eux
on va parler de leur maison de leur
territoire de leur bon ils peuvent voir
ils peuvent être
à côté
et
alors en attendant les jeux il y a aussi
parce qu'on est en 2023 la dernière
étape du Tour de France qui partira du
du Vélodrome il y a aussi Paris-Nice qui
va partir de la verrière là aussi c'est
important pour le territoire enfin c'est
des fiertés aussi je suppose alors bien
sûr avec ces sur ces quatre sites si on
enlève le golf il nous en reste trois
uniquement vélo qui est évident qu'on
sent bien l'image capital du Mondial du
vélo la dernière il y a le Tour de
France c'est la dernière étape du Tour
de France qui part du Vélodrome ensuite
le Paris-Nice bien entendu on sent on
sent bien que
la terre du vélo quoi les championnats
du monde qui se passe ici enfin bien sûr
ça devient c'est pour ça qu'on est
obligé de passer de 400 km parce que 100
km mais bon
ça coûte quand même ça coûte 37 millions
seulement
on est très quand même terrain on n'est
pas des des intellos et cetera il en
faut quelques-uns je veux dire bon mais
mais pour diriger faut bien suivre
il y a une cohérence d'avoir marqué par
l'innovation
marqué par une bonne gestion aussi un je
vous rappelle quand même qu'on est
classé de a pas une course on a diminué
dette de 25%. j'aimerais bien que l'État
mais j'ai pas eu cette information
encore
une milliards donc oui oui on va vers
3000 mon avion 3600 milliards à la fin
de ce mandat donc vous aurez vous aviez
1800 milliards de dettes en 2012 vous
serez 3600 à la fin de ce mandat c'est
exactement le double donc
oui mais il y a eu la crise en Allemagne
aussi il y a il n'y a pas des montants
un mot sur la santé vous parlez du
vaccinodrome tout à l'heure qui a été en
effet vous le disiez c'est ce qu'on
regarde de plus aujourd'hui encore sur
ce territoire vous il y a aussi le
projet de l'hôpital 2.0
en quoi en quelques mots en quoi ça
consiste alors l'hôpital de point zéro
c'est bien sûr
idem c'est comme la sécurité c'est comme
c'est comme bien sûr l'éducation c'est
vraiment la révolution technologique
est-ce que elle touche la santé de
quelle façon donc voilà nous on dit
il est pas possible de continuer à ce
que à nos concitoyens attendent trois
six mois pour voir un spécialiste
c'est pas tenable c'est pas tenable on
va pas vouloir être un grand pays voilà
donc nous je dis pas que on va se loger
ça comme ça pour demain matin 9h mais on
se penche là dessus on voit l'apport de
la technologie moi j'étais encore au
salon
mondial au plus grand salon mondial de
l'innovation aux États-Unis
comme on était aussi à l'Exposition
Universelle enfin à chaque fois on est
quand même invité parce qu'on est très
innovant on porte aussi les startups
on voit donc le monde qui évolue oui il
y a des il y a une révolution
technologique qui se passe qui impacte
direct la santé donc nous on veut plutôt
être plutôt en avance que en retard je
dis pas que alors bon après on voit bien
qu'il y a des il y a une partie de la
médecine qui peuvent se faire demain
dans une télécabine pas tout pas vous
faire opérer dans une télécabine bien
sûr mais je veux dire que en répondant à
un médecin aux questions voilà vous
gagnez un temps considérable sur le
patient et elle peut avoir une
prescription médicale voilà mais tout ce
qui est bien sûr plus lourd j'ai entendu
ça passe par la procédure normale bien
sûr de voir un médecin physiquement mais
nous on est on travaille sur les deux on
travaille je dis pas que je dis là mais
je peux vous dire la demande est-elle
parce que en plus les gens ont
l'impression que Saint-Quentin a dit
moyen alors
c'est vrai qu'on s'en sort mais je veux
dire que on vit aussi la crise vous
savez quand on nous enlève 47 millions
de CVAE en nous disant vous serez mais
on verra comment bon donc tout de même
même Saint-Quentin est quand même touché
donc mais on essaye de prioriser les
choses et la santé ça l'est comme
l'éducation celle l'est à l'éducation
oui poursuivait toujours cette le
numérique dans l'éducation c'était
c'était un des temps forts de de votre
mandat de ce que vous avez fait déjà
Élancourt puis ici là aussi ça continue
ça s'étend sur tout le territoire bah
aujourd'hui l'éducation nationale a
monté une école à
Élancourt en cours 50 en Yvelines on
forme 4000 profs
à la révolution pédagogique par le
numérique bon tout ça c'est bon signe
bien sûr on est en même temps on est en
ça maintenant au collège avec le Conseil
départemental au lycée
au niveau bien sûr enseignement
supérieur avec l'université
donc c'est parti dire c'est
extraordinaire ce modèle en fait on voit
premièrement qu'il augmente le plaisir
d'enseigner les profs c'est quand même
pas mal et il augmente le plaisir
d'apprendre des élèves je peux vous dire
il croyez un combat les fractures
sociales et réduit la fracture sociale
il lutte contre l'échec scolaire donc
que c'est un succès donc ça continue à
monter on met beaucoup de moyens
là-dessus et aujourd'hui 50 ans on
Yvelines porte le projet éducatif à mon
avis le plus le plus opérationnel en
termes d'innovation en France en plus la
notoriété de Paris circle ne nuit pas
bien entendu à cette avancée alors votre
culture il y a des grands travaux pour
le théâtre de Saint-Quentin
et puis vous y allusion sur la base de
loisirs il va y avoir un grand concert
avec grand DJ c'est ça alors eux
absolument il y a un grand concert
[Musique]
qu'on a présenté le bilan de
Saint-Quentin là sur grand écran on se
croirait chez Apple avec Steve Jobs qui
explique sa vision du monde j'ai trouvé
cette réflexion
mais c'est vrai ici on travaille sur sur
tous les grands sujets du monde et on
essaye d'aller voir à l'étranger comment
ça se passe les meilleurs de trouver des
délais montages financiers de nos de nos
de nos partenaires qui soient chercheurs
qui soient université qui soit
entreprise bon on va chercher du fric
sur l'Europe on va à l'état à la région
au département donc on accompagne
vraiment
la un peu cette cette innovation qui est
quand même la solution je pense que
demain la solution au grand problème de
notre pays la révolution technologique
va donner un sacré coup de main donc
nous on essaie d'être vraiment sur cet
axe là et je pense que regarder même on
a même le ministre du numérique aussi
Qui est qui était là et qui joue un rôle
très parce que c'est un secteur
extrêmement strat donc voilà non on est
il y a un certain
d'abord de mes collaborateurs ça ne
fierté de travailler sur tous ces
dossiers il y a plutôt une bonne
ambiance on a des partenaires puissants
de Paris c'est clair à la région de
département de l'État
s'énerve on a une jolie ce qu'on
parlementaire pour modifier des lois
enfin on va pas tout modifier mais déjà
il y a quand même quelques amendements
tant qu'ils passent bon côté au
Parlement voilà vous avez été députés
vous êtes maire vous êtes président de
Saint-Quentin il y a il y a cette année
il y a des élections sénatoriales où ça
vous intéresse pas du tout non ah non ah
non mais le Parlement
au Sénat alors j'ai trois fois députés
bon aujourd'hui malheureusement il faut
bien le dire les députés ont été
dépouillés de leur pouvoir
l'administration à tous les pouvoirs bon
écoutez c'est un choix de de qui
existait déjà que Monsieur Macron a
plutôt renforcé leur compensé qu'il
allait faire plutôt le contraire mais
bon le Sénat c'est pareil c'est quand
même très difficile vous avez pas vous
avez pas un grand pouvoir donc ici oui
je pense que aujourd'hui
ce sont l'innovation et dans les
Territoires les solutions sont sur le
terrain dans les territoires c'est un
beau territoire 50 ans Yvelines un
discutablement je vous dis ici on se
concerne à 12 mers après on prend la
décision boom ça a beaucoup plus vite
que que
donc vous êtes un président heureux
honnêtement c'est passionnant et quand
vous travaillez sur des autant de sujets
d'intérêt général et et avec quand même
un certain avec certains résultats oui
vous êtes heureux c'est bien sûr que
c'est hyper passionnant merci beaucoup
[Musique]